Hey look guys my name is achernar and i
thought i would do like a weekly update
type vlog deal where I sort of just talk
to you guys about well it's been going
on in the week I thought I'd also answer
some questions that you guys might have
for me and you know just in general
update you guys with what's going on and
and what's coming you know on this
channel and stuff like that so I'm I'm
um I'm not Melvin but right now you
probably tell I am um I'm gonna Berry
Farm basically focus check out those
sweet blueberries so I'm talking about
so yeah that's where I'm at right now
um focus damn it so that is what is up
with the scenery so enjoy the view I
thought I thought I'd do the first
episode out here in the wilderness just
I just call I can so um as I sort of um
I'm sort of 82 berries um I thought that
first of all it's not a saying thank you
for 8.4 K subscribers it's a lot of
thanks and I hope you guys are having a
good Christmas break because um I am
ultimately Kristen is rice more like a
Christmas / New Year break type deal I
haven't I've been I've been relaxing I'm
just playing some games or pretty much
all my friends have left so that's fun
but I don't know my family saying in
Melbourne for this year's new year um
we've always gone somewhere you know
interstate usually but this time we're
gonna be staying in Melbourne so yeah
but we're sort of you know just went out
today just for Saturday just for today
this is Saturday actually you'd be
watching this on Sunday but today's
Saturday but yeah set Sunday night is
usually gonna be the weekly vlog off
daytime weekly update you know video but
um yeah I don't thing I want to talk
about and I don't know Irish cut this a
few times I'll probably cut this cuz I'm
just going on about nothing
there's gonna be caught here
all right the other thing I wanted to
mention is a lot of you guys might have
remembered that I actually had a
minecraft server that I sort of hosted
from my own computer and it usually it
wasn't really up it was up for like 12
hours at a time was up it was up when I
was up basically because I like to shut
down my computer and turn off my routers
and everything when I go to bed so I
didn't keep the computer on all night
obviously I used up a lot of energy as
well or power but I actually made a new
server I actually bought server hosting
from a front place called like multi
players on this that was actually hosted
in Sydney which is good for me because
it's in Australia and I get like less
than 50 more second ping to it which is
great it doesn't lag at all it's
brilliant but it's open to everyone it's
24/7 it's up to 30 people it's got 2
gigs of RAM it's faith-based that's one
thing you actually need to know it's
feed the based and what feed the based
is it's like a mod pack so it's
basically like check it right it has um
I don't even know if you guys do the
same you by the way you should be able
to its like check it right it's got um
it's got industrial craft it's got build
craft it's got its got like it's got all
that cool stuff
it's even got like the Twilight forests
and stuff like that it's it's great it's
pretty huge I've been playing it through
people I've actually announced it on
this channel yet or on my other channel
actually but I've sort of through
Twitter and live streams I guess I've
sort of you know this there's a good
there's a good amount of people playing
there's like usually five to ten people
online right now which is cool but well
it's open to all of you guys all you
need is feed the base you literally go
to feed the base Google fade the base
well I'll put a link in the description
because you guys are not capable of that
but if you gotta feed the base do you
download the client the if you if you're
on Windows you download the exe if
you're on Linux or Mac you download the
jar file
you know same [ __ ] different day and
basically you get to you know you just
you select the feed the base like beta
mode that make sure you don't select
like the voxel mode whatever you need
fade the basement pack you selected in
the client and then you just it
downloads and then you launch it and
then it's great you connect to the
server and it adds so much cool it adds
like power generators and for those of
you haven't played it it's really cool
takes a while to learn I'm still trying
to learn it but it's amazing I thought
it'd be more I thought be better than
just
vanilla minecraft cervical I'm sort of
getting bored of that stuff me yeah so I
did that which is cool so that server
the URL to that so so that the IP to
that server is minecraft the Cherno comm
:
two nine six six five all right the port
is two nine six sixty five twenty nine
thousand six hundred sixty five yeah
again the IPA will be in the description
that'll be up 24/7
yeah it's pvp griefing is not
technically allowed alright now i'm not
to be kind of griefing but if it's a pvp
server it's hard not agree so what i'm
gonna do guys is you can grief but hey
listen l-listen listen up you cannot
directly destroy blocks alright if you
see someone's house you can use 10t can
use explosives or fire to destroy it but
you can't - can use tools basically you
can use that stuff because it is warfare
basically but you cannot go up with a
pickaxe and destroy everything and no
you can't do if I kept you doing that
you're banned ban hammer boom but you
can you can actually you know set on a
fire if it's a wooden house I think my
house actually got been downed this
morning I haven't checked yet but my
friends that letter to me about so
whoever did that oh yeah sure knows
house BAM ban hammer yeah yeah that's
right in my house you don't touch that
[ __ ] yeah also a lot of people think I
might be cheating I'm not actually
cheating on the server I am I'm
obviously an RP but I'm actually doing
this without cheating which is really
cool because on the other server I did
shave basically I support myself some
ridiculous ancient anomalous about that
but this I'm actually doing legit just
because it's more fun basically and just
cuz there's so much so many things
there's so many different all's in
anyway I'm not gonna go on about that
because you guys you guys get the drill
point is the eyepiece and description
now if you want to see more minecraft
videos remember I did actually upload a
video where I said that I was changing
channels not changing channels making
another channel just for gaming and then
keeping only programming stuff on this
channel the link to that channel is
obviously the channel name is the mr.
churner alright and the link is in the
description so if you want more
Minecraft videos and stuff like that
subscribe to that I'm actually doing
like a fade the base single-player
playthrough like a let's play for that
listen like video a day and I'm also
doing a lot of um
black ops 2 zombies and multiplayer
Sullivan anyway there's loads on that
channel and there's actually gonna be
specific feed the base server like
tutorials I have build certain things
and fade the base and strategies that I
found and some of that on that new
channel so again channel 2 that the link
to that channel is you to become full /
then mr. churner blackberry alright okay
okay
I also a few questions on I asked I
tweeted out that I was um doing this and
he got soft questions a lot a few
questions well I'm gonna ask not too
many because this video is getting a bit
long but um first question was is my
minecraft server host locally or do I
have company I mean am i hosting it
through a host and the answer is yeah
for a host multiply answer that other
actually alright second question was my
upload schedule um I usually upload you
know aliens to standard time of course
that's right actually it's Australian
daylight standard time environment I
upload um I uploaded new game
programming videos at around 9 to 10
p.m. anywhere from 8 to 10 p.m. Eastern
Daylight Time that's usually when
they'll pull off usually around 9 p.m.
now the other thing is do I recommend
any books for people getting programming
um Java for dummies is great if you're
still trying to learn Java if you know
javis always my fingers in the web the
camera right away
um you already know Java check out these
blackberries I've collected so if you
can see him yeah there we go if you
already know Java and game programming
then there's it be called Atilla game
programming in Java
very good book from 2005 I recommend is
very good books the other thing is it's
really advanced to Java and you just you
know you really want to learn the
fundamentals and the concepts for actual
game programming
game programming gems I think that's
what's called there's a whole series I
wasn't there really good but I'm not
kill game programming in Java very good
book covers everything from 2d to 3d to
multiply
and it's it's great so yeah that's a
storybook cipher but recommend yeah
check out this few guys it's great and
the final thing is um a lot of people
we're asking what's up with a 3d game
programming serious that's it's gonna
come back when I'm comfortable bringing
it back sorry I've got a lot on my plate
right now I'm from a game programming as
well as a bunch of lot of stuff and I'm
actually working on a big project that
few of you guys know so that's taking up
a lot of my time but as soon as I sort
of you know soon as I get a more clear
schedule I'm gonna get back to 3d and
running in Java yeah all right
the game programming that's gonna come
back like next week so off to off to New
Year's Day it's gonna come back and
that's gonna be daily when it comes back
so yeah rejoice but yeah that is the
weekly update number one and this like
dislocation is actually um I know it's
exactly fifty kilometers from my house
because I drove here from by using GPS
that's why I'm running and Bashur right
now cuz i phone GPS google maps by the
way there's an app for iphone now called
Google Maps so in other words they
brought it back is obviously Apple Maps
was rubbish so Google actually made
their own app it's amazing it's free it
comes with the GPS so like that TomTom
GPS for iPhone
there was like $99 that I actually never
bought but I've one of my friends did
and it was decent this has a fridge ETS
now it's ridiculous free GPS dude like
it's like a normal TomTom GPS but Google
Maps and it is so precise it's
unbelievable it's actually like the best
JPS I've ever used and I just who's
blu-tack to to BlueTEC my iphone to my
dashboard on my car and I drove here and
it was flawless and you can see the burn
Hills right now so it wasn't it wasn't
an easy road and the GPS was just
spot-on every time it was amazing um so
yeah anyway guys that's going to wrap up
this weekly thing and I'll see you guys
well I'll see you guys next week with a
new weekly vlog but otherwise game
programming episodes beginning on
Wednesday Thursday
so yeah let guys bye-bye